قضاه محكمه العدل الدوليه حسموا امرهم
طلبوا اسرائيل اسقاط دعوى الاباده
الجماعيه ضدها مرفوض وعليها تغيير سلوكها
الحربي في
غزه تخلص المحكمه الى ان لديها الولايه
القضائيه لبت القضيه وتعتبر انه لا يمكنها
قبول طلب اسرائيل اسقاطها يجب على اسرائيل
وفقا لالتزاماتها بموجب اتفاقيه الاباده
الجماعيه اتخاذ كل التدابير ضمن سلطاتها
لمنع اي اعمال تندرج ضمن الماده الثانيه
في الاتفاقيه الاعمال المشار اليها في
الماده المذكوره هي القتل والحاق الضرر
الجسدي او المعنوي بالفلسطينيين وخلق ظروف
قاسيه
لمعيشتهم القضاه خصوا الجيش الاسرائيلي
تحديدا بامرهم الاحترازي الثاني وطالب
القضاه حكومه نتنياهو بمنع وعقاب تصريحات
مسؤوليه التحريضي
امر القضاه باجراءات فوريه وفعاله لايصال
المساعدات المحكمه امرت تلابي بعدم منع او
تقييد وصول بعثات تقص الحقائق والمفتشين
والزمت الحكومه الاسرائيليه بتقديم تقرير
عن التزامها بهذه الاجراءات بعد شهر من
الام اعتقد اننا بحاجه الى حكم المحكمه
بعنايه فائقه لقد اصدروا تعليمات مباشره
للغايه ونحن مقتنعون بان التدابير المؤقته
التي سعينا الى معالجتها ستعالج المحكمه
واعتقد ان مساله كيفيه اداره الحرب او
الصراع لم تفصل كنت ارغب في ادراج كلمه
وقف في
الحكم لم تامر محكمه العدل الدوليه
اسرائيل بوقف حربها على غزه لكن اسرائيل
لا تزال في قفص الاتهام تحاكم بتهمه
الاباده الجماعيه وستظل كذلك ربما لسنوات
طويله اما هؤلاء المتظاهرون فيرون في
اقرار المحكمه تدابير مؤقته تاكيدا لشبهه
ارتكاب الجريمه وخطوه اولى على درب
العداله
الطويل
[تصفيق]
فقد بدا لكثير من الحاضرين انه ما من
امكانيه عمليه لالتزام اسرائيل بامر
المحكمه سوى بوقف الحرب لا اطلاقا لسنا
محبطين على الاطلاق بالعكس يعني انا
مستغرب من هذا
الشعور ما حدث ان المحكمه استجابت لجل
الطلبات التي تم تقديمها من قبل فريق
القانون الطلبات التمهيديه وحكمت بها
وحكمت بها خلال مده قياسيه عمليا من اجل
تنفيذ هذه الطلبات التي طلبتها المحكمه
على اسرائيل ان توقف اطلاق
النار عندما جئنا الى هنا كنا نامل الافضل
ولكننا مستعدون ونتوقع الاسوا حصلنا على
اكثر مما توقعنا ان نحصل عليه لذلك كل
الناس هنا يتحلون بالامل بان نمضي قدما في
نضالنا الطويل
الحكم ابتدائي والتدابير مؤقته لكنها
بالنسبه الى الفريق القانوني لجنوب
افريقيا انتصار لهم وهزيمه لنظرائهم
المدافعين عن اسرائيل ومع ان المحكمه
لتملك وسائل انفاذ اوامرها الملزمه
بطبيعتها فان تطبيقها يضع الجميع امام
اختبار سياسي واخلاقي محمد المدهون
الجزيره لاهاي
al